[Music]
in fair or nah news submitted by move
your joints a rabbi found guilty of
money laundering is spared prison time a
rabbi or rabbis the ones with the curly
sideburns yeah there's the one with the
fluffy tails my friends but do they all
have to go that's like that's like super
Orthodox right Oh like do you need to
have Mandela
that's a yarmulke I don't know what I
thought were you thinking the Mandela
effect for some marquales I don't know
why I love that game um no so this
rabbis from New Jersey Joisey he was
found guilty of laundering two hundred
thousand dollars from a private school
for children with developmental
disabilities
he founded this school inspired by his
own son special meaningful this feels
like I can borrow it it's mine I started
this kind of pretty much that's what
seems to happen it all depends on intent
what was the money going to - starts a
clothing brand
what businessman yeah why would i under
the clothing game he wanted to get into
street wear imagine yeah it's called has
a parallel LC I don't know I think it's
for the special needs lifestyle mmm it's
all waterproof stairs apparel this is
high quality cotton yeah durable durable
here is that he pulled money from the
school start this clothing business and
then he somehow laundered that money to
make it seem like it was his own funds
and then put it back into the school oh
this is confused so he sounds like he's
cleaning cash yeah money laundry
des Ling he's washing it somehow yeah he
washes it but he used so he's probably
getting it out funding the apparel
whatever profits or whatever he's
getting from it I'm assuming he's
getting profits it goes to his account
because he pays himself from that
account and then from there he he's it
back he pays it back to this pool or I
don't know if he's back or says I'm
donating more when does a rabbi become a
fashion expert that's what I'm like
wondering when that shift happens that's
why I've started this school which
obviously probably cost millions of
dollars right yeah and he goes wait I'm
gonna take two hundred thousand these
are all this is which makes me think
that the Mafia is behind this it reminds
me of like the Jewish like it's just so
opposite right like you got you got a
pastor that's also a DJ it's like that
it's like so what happened here was so
they're saying that he's siphoned four
hundred and thirty thousand dollars from
a fund raising foundation damn and then
so like he did that from the school to
invest in the colonia company but then
in another article they're talking about
two hundred thousand so I don't know he
should quit while he's ahead like a four
week child and they're saying that
during this whole trial though is very
emotional people were crying a lot of
people were standing up and like
speaking on his behalf I'm like he's
such a great man he's helped this school
he does a lot for the school and so
using and pardoning pardoning what's up
well I guess so he's 62 and I guess the
judge thinks like you know as he said at
this stage in at this stage in this
man's life I cannot imagine that this
situation could ever occur again the
sickness of the allegations and the harm
that occurred is much less than what
this court typically sees with other
second-degree crimes because he was
charged he was found guilty of
second-degree charges the money's money
laundering and misconduct by a corporate
official and so there's they usually
focus a the judges point of view like if
you did a crime that didn't really hurt
anybody
I mean it's hurting the trust
more like the shame on don't do that
hurting the trust of people that are
donating think this money is going to
what his what his promised what it is
still cuz he's not embezzling hidden
taking it so like the mountain the money
that way poor is going back we don't
know that so for me I'm like heared he
did something shady that got caught for
what other stuff has he been doing you
know what I mean yeah to me it just
seems like he moved money
inappropriately yeah so he didn't
technically steal from yeah he put the
money back into it as a way to invest in
his own company yeah so he took a loan
basically I find this very difficult
why'd he just take a normal no because
no I bet his clothing company sucks well
or does it well be hard to get a loan on
that yeah yeah I tried googling it but
because the donation money is intended
for the school and what he did illegally
was siphoning that money out into his
personal project I know this is sounding
all very Robin hoodie to me I find it
very hard to believe that a Jewish man
can't get a loan bingo interest-free
loan though Noatak see that's pretty
good
nothing is without retribution in the
eyes of the Lord but yeah so they're
saying that usually this second-degree
charge can carry sentences of five to
ten years and state prison she's not
gonna last yeah what for him all he has
to do is serve sixty days in a County
Correctional Facility and pay a fine of
two hundred and fifty thousand dollars
just that's pretty that's still
crippling and he will still be able to
be involved with the school you just
can't touch the finances so that's like
that's kind of why this made the news
because I like how crazy the rabbi like
not allowed to touch the money and the
priests are like not allowed to touch
boys the universe really works in
strange ways
see now I really want to see his
clothing line I
you gotta see oh [ __ ] it's like hip-hop
Street where what if he has this passion
for like hip-hop Street high die hippy
[ __ ]
he doesn't look too terrible I could
tell where that might be funny he likes
making little shorts and [ __ ] yeah it's
all Coachella like this doesn't look
like the face of someone who's going off
I [ __ ] up like you know what I mean
like the headlines it says rabbi found
guilty of money laundering won't go to
prison thanks to selfless life judge
says so like that's why it's such a big
deal cuz he's not going to prison
he's gonna go to thanks there are some
weird laws though on how you move money
some stuff that I don't agree with but I
have to abide by because it's illegal if
I don't and one of them is so so they
during I think the Reagan administration
there was something called the wire act
and that's if you deposit anything over
ten thousand dollars the bank has to
make a report because that all happened
because of drug lords were just
depositing [ __ ] tons of money so there
are people out there that know of this
but they're misinformed and then they
think that oh it troubles the bank to
deposit more than 10,000 so then what
they'll do is they'll put six thousand
here five thousand there and some people
that have cash businesses they do this
all the time they have the records for
it but they do it right and it's called
it's not called scattering but there's
there's a name for that and that's also
illegal and there's been people who've
received money legitimately like cafe
owners or whatever and then they deposit
this money and in the IRS will come and
seize that money and then they'll just
take it from you and they'll freeze your
account yeah and then you have to go
through this huge battles yeah only
because you did it because you're
depositing cash even if you have the
records for it so they take it first
they freeze your account and then you
have to fight for it and that's [ __ ]
up yeah cuz some people will tell you
know like some parent might tell you
like oh don't deposit more than ten
thousand because you know if you do that
you know they have to go through so much
more work so just you know when you get
money from the coin laundry or whatever
like just deposit it scattered yeah and
then so there's a lot of cases where
they
and I'm like that's [ __ ] up and that
diving that's [ __ ] up that the IRS has
so much power over your private property
even if you're a legitimate business
owner and you report income and you do
all that stuff legitimately what instead
of scattering what are you supposed to
do all at once yeah whatever you get you
just put so yeah they say to just split
it up but apparently it's up to the bank
manager so they have to report it if
it's weird so like you come in monthly
not it's not up to the bank manager you
you always have to do this thing called
a CTR
she works for typing yeah it your whole
[ __ ] gets blocked and you and it blocks
you your screen you can't do anything
else you have to get the information the
amount the way that it's broken down
like every single time but you're
talking about the scattering part right
like if you if I were to come in with
like 11k of cash it was like I'm
depositing this yeah they have to do
anything overtime
don't they go like Oh where'd you get
this money for don't they go through
like an informal like basically
interview no they don't know the bank
doesn't do any of that real yeah so the
only time the manager will get involved
is if they start noticing a pattern
right like you come in every single day
and you keep depositing ten initial or
he'll notice that you're like okay two
thousand here two and then they're like
well that's kind of suspicious that's
right oh no and like send it up
if someone's depositing 9999 dollars
every single day 99 cents with the bank
manager will alert the authorities or
whatever but there are a lot of cases
where let's say you own a cash business
right like whether it's laundromat or
whatever and you do this all the time
and bait and then you do this under your
laundromat LLC or whatever the bank
account is then they they have this I
forgot what it do you know what it is
but it's kind of like a free pass for
that business where you don't get [ __ ]
up because they don't flip business has
that yeah they have like a separate
business deposit no they have that
because they always come in with a lot
of cash so it takes a long ass huh yeah
could you have to do the counting
accounting but yeah but I think I mean
oh it'll get flagged but after a certain
pattern is developed and the system
recognizes it
doesn't happen as often or it will still
get reported but now your information is
saved so it's just like a copy and paste
yeah but yeah that I think that was
that's kind of [ __ ] up is that they
just freeze your account and you're
doing it all legitimate but then you got
to take it takes years for you to get
that money back
and you just take it from you don't
spend all our cash let's buy some useful
[ __ ] yeah it's crazy stupid Amazon dude
stupid [ __ ] Amazon always gets me
spending all the money if anything what
are you buying on there it's go to Vegas
random [ __ ] it was the last thing you
bought last thing that I bought know
what I thought I bought these I bought a
six-pack of silicone mats Oh what
because for when I can plug me I knew it
but then did I need six absolutely well
you never know he's another five exactly
I think it's like you can get odd stuff
like I bought a hundred-foot ethernet
cable see hundred well how about a
dustpan that I need a long one but I was
like I'm not gonna go to Best Buy yeah
I'll be like I need an Ethernet cable
don't be like what's that yeah that's
right I don't know anything I don't know
what you need it for for my X Xbox Xbox
what I needed I needed my max internet
speed man she thought called up to right
now you're not even using the whole run
just stretch it out I got a pin in
around the thing if you go to Best Buy
and you go I need a computer - Billa
what's that
would you mind you a tooth so but tooth
wait no your lives and we always battle
like I'd like I'm [ __ ] slightly OCD
so like with the toothpaste
I like to like roll it up and then make
it neat so everything gets pushed up to
the top and I leave it and it's perfect
this [ __ ] savage comes in the drawer
grabs it and squeezes it so now it's
awful would you squeeze it from the
center no man you just got annoying
cuz we something like I'm not gonna do
this should you get the roller pinkie I
bought that
no metal thing you slide it in then you
just took a turn key type thing it looks
like like Sherlock Holmes is rolling
this is like an OCD it's toothpaste I
gotta look into this I love it's the
best so now every time I go get
toothbrush it's like all the way to the
top and what [ __ ] yeah I win because I
think I'm 300 G so like I get to benefit
from OCD